la réalité quelle est elle c'est l'échec
des manuels macron c'est un échec social
je vous renvoie au gilet jaune toujours
pas disparu et on sent qu'il faut une
allumette pour ça redémarre c'est un
échec grattoir jamais notre pays n'a
accueilli autant d'étrangers dans toute
son histoire sur le notre territoire
c'est un échec sécuritaire puisque on
sait maintenant on a les chiffres qui
montrent que les vols avaient augmenté
avec violences augmentent et 18% que les
rixes ont augmenté de 60% bref et ainsi
de suite c'est un échec en matière
d'endettement puisque nous avons accru
notre endettement de 700 milliards ce
qu' aucun pays n'a fait donne
aujourd'hui
les 100 milliards des 700 mineurs c'est
pas elle a donc j'essaie de son milieu
en
échec eux deux en matière d'endettement
échecs en matière éducatif je voudrais
continuer la liste des échecs mais je
vais surtout vous dire la conclusion que
j'en tire est pourquoi il faut qu'une
alternance et que cette alternance c'est
valérie pécresse
avec cette même politique
avec ces mêmes équipes
je vous la firme dans les dix ans qui
viennent la france sera expulsé des dix
premières puissances mondiales choix
pardon aujourd'hui c'est pas entre eux
emmanuel macron eric zemmour s'est pas
entrer manuel mâcon et marie le pen
s'est pas entrer manuel macro et jean
luc mélenchon s'est pas entre eux
emmanuel macron et madame hidalgo parce
que tout ceci ce sont des courants
d'opinion qui sont connus qui sont
respectables qui sont plus ou moins
importants qui sont les jumelles qu'est
qu'ils ont chacun leur légitimité ce
sont des courants d'opinion mais pardon
l'alternance l'alternative n'y a qu'une
personne qui peut la réaliser
écoutez c'était fait moi vous parlez des
sondages écoutez vous venu parler des
sondages c'est bien que ça j'ai pas été
sourd tout à l'heure môme avait évoqué
les sens et je constate aujourd'hui et
c'est ma conviction au-delà des enquêtes
d'opinion que la seule possibilité de
mettre fin à aucun cas fans
renouvellement d'un quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron c'est valérie pécresse
estimé que cette raison ce sont des
candidatures de témoignage la
candidature des verts et pécresse c'est
pour gagner